Jordan, this is exciting.
What are we about to do?
We're about to go on the hunt for Tuscan truffles,
the very rare fungus that only grows
at certain times of the year.
Anything we need to know about hunting for truffles?
(speaking in foreign language)
No, we don't need to know anything before.
All that to hear we didn't need to know anything?
(audience laughing)
So you're sure these dogs serve a purpose?
They do something?
They go this way?
What is that?
Is that a truffle?
That's a truffle, right?
Theses dogs just found a truffle.
Wait.
What's this?
You found another one?
(speaking in foreign language)
Look at this.
They just found another one.
Psst, get in here.
(audience chuckling)
I strongly suspect these guys,
because they knew we were coming,
hid these ahead of time
(audience laughs)
because they're finding them very easily.
Don't you think so?
I concur.
They keep going, "Oh, look, a-the truffle."
And we're barely even looking for them.
Can you get down like you're a truffle pig.
Do you mind?
Sure.
Oink oink, oink oink.
(audience laughing)
Get out of the way!
A truffle!
You did it.
Good job, Oinky.
Thank you.
That's as legitimate as anything
these guys have been doing.
I'm sorry but we've been scammed.
(audience laughing)
What I would like to do
is go very deep into the woods,
and once we are very, very deep in the woods,
I would like-
(Jordan speaking foreign language)
-to kill my friend.
That's okay?
They don't mind.
Fantastic.
I love these guys, let's go.
(audience laughing)
Ask him where the pigs are right now.
Do you use pigs?
(speaking foreign language)
No, it's prohibited.
You can't use pigs here.
Tell him that I might wish to use rabbits
to find my truffles.
Why does the government care if I use a rabbit-
Because the rabbit doesn't have the nose for it.
Oh, I'm sick of the rabbit
being subjugated in this country.
I think I'm losing my mind.
It's very cold and very dark.
I don't know these guys and I'm with Jordan.
And they said it was okay for me to kill Jordan.
These dogs are finding truffles
that have been hidden clearly minutes before we got here.
This whole thing's a goddamn scam.
(Conan fake laughs)
(audience laughing)
I feel that he works harder than he does.
Lui's always in the corner like this.
Oh.
A companion at work who does nothing.
You're Lui.
I am the truffle hunter.
I do all the work at The late night show.
You apparently do nothing.
You stand off to the side,
yet you get to share in the truffles
that I have dug in the earth with my hands.
We came hunting for truffles,
instead we found a nugget of truth.
(audience laughs)